Wear your own personal signature as jewelry,
Put on your pink doughnut sweatshirt,
And give out some free hugs because LUT is
back...
Dress up your cat with this solar system fascinator
After making him or her workout on this cat
exercise wheel
And then foil its evil feline plot by reading
the book "How to tell if your cat is plotting
to kill you"
If the cat succeeds - at least you'll finally
have a use for this bacon coffin
Make breakfast instead of rotting in it with
this blood dripping cutting board
And drink some coffee out of your mug made
in... or of China
Grand Illusions is a great website that sells
illusions like the Einstein hollow face or
these reversing goggles that let you see the
world upside down.
They also have magnetic toys like this Han
Dynasty compass and gag gifts like this ridiculously
awesome and dangerous magic candle for your
birthday cake.
But if your sweet tooth calls for cookies
instead of cake use this cookie monster mug
so you can have your cookies (and coffee)
and eat them too
Or just have some tea... made from a man-a-tee......
infuser
Don't forget to brush your teeth with some
freshly vomited toothpaste.
Then put on these super cool glow in the dark
sunglasses so you can finally wear them at
night
And strap on your USB bracelet so you don't
lose all of your important information.
Available at getonhand.com they come in a
variety of colors and designs
If you're a little more old fashioned try
this USB in a bottle to get your message across
Or send an actual letter typed on your vintage
typewriter
If you're still bored just use this book of
642 things to draw including a beetle, a turntable,
your least favorite food and a bowl of pudding
Or play with some magnetic putty from Vat19.com
that is hungry for magnets.
Prove your constitutional knowledge with your
right to bear arms..... shirt
And do some fashionable reading with these
children's book necklaces including Where
the Wild Things Are, Harry Potter, and the
Hobbit
If books aren't your thing play with these
retro smart phone cases that let you play
classic ball and maze games on the back of
your phone
Or go outside and play with this awesome starfighter
pool toy
If you get hungry from all that action eat
some food off of a cloud.... serving tray
Add a little frigid spice with these snow
globe salt and pepper shakers
Or make it sweeter with Unicorn sprinkles
Or just do nothing because today has been
cancelled...pillow
And as always, thanks for watching.